عشرات القنوات المحليه والدوليه امام
المحكمه العليا في لندن تتابع مقاضاه
الامير هاري وشخصيات مشهوره لصحيفه ميرو
لنشرها معلومات عنهم بشكل غير قانوني
لكن بعد كل الانتظار لم ترصد الكاميرات
وصول الامير هاري لغيابه عن الجلسه
الافتتاحيه في المحكمه لاسباب تتعلق بعرض
بيانات وادله تتطلب يوما كاملا بحسب
محاميه وهو ما اعتبره فريق الدفاع صحيفه
مضيعه للوقت خصوصا وانه يريد التدقيق في
ادله المرافعه باستجواب الامير هاري كشاهد
لدحض ادعاءاته بان نشر معلوماته كانت بطرق
غير شرعيه
سواء ربح او خسر القضيه فهو يريد احراج
وسائل الاعلام وبعض افراد العائله المالكه
من خلال هذه المحاكمه فهذه بالنسبه له
حمله يصر على قيادتها فيما يعتقد الاخرون
انه هوس مرضي
الامير هذه اختار المواجهه والادلاء
بافادته كاول شاهد لفرد من العائله
الملكيه منذ اكثر من قرن من الزمن يحمل
الصحف الشعبيه مسؤوليه مقتل والده ديانا
واضطراب علاقته بالعائله الملكه التي دابت
على التجنب المحاكم لمنع الادلاء بشهادتها
بشان امور قد تكون محرجه يوم تاريخي في
القضاء البريطاني عندما يدلي الامير هاري
بشهادته في المحكمه وقد يكشف المزيد من
اسرار العائله المالكه ليعمق خلافته معها
ومخالفه التقليد بمقابضات الصحيفه على ما
يزعم ضد رغبات والدي الملك تشارلز الذي
يقضي اجازه خاصه في رومانيا مصطفى العربيه
لندن لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات